[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler-free review
of shadow and bone i will also be having
a spoiler review breaking out every
episode coming out
in the next couple days but for this
obviously no spoilers and also no
spoilers from the books here i will not
be talking about the books i have not
read the books i don't plan on reading
the books please do not talk about the
books anywhere on this
comment section so going into this show
i am usually a big fantasy fan and i was
excited because
i heard good things about the books ben
barnes is in the show
and it's netflix so you think okay it's
gonna come through
so for me i think this is a very mixed
show meaning it's good it's got great
and it's got awful and i think that it
has a nice blend of it all
meaning you're gonna get it in different
doses so i think like
really what i would say about this show
is that if you are a
hardcore fantasy fan you're gonna enjoy
the show and i think it's
totally worth a watch if you're not a
hardcore fantasy fan
i do not think this is gonna be one that
appeals to just anybody i don't think
it's something that like anyone will
watch game of thrones or
something like a stranger things or the
witcher it's not like that
you have to be okay with eye roll
moments and what i mean by that is
it feels a lot of time like something
you'd watch on that show like once upon
a time where
it's like that hip fantasy where
someone's got a cool hat on or
you're just like oh my god like it's
really
corny in moments but some people like
that and i think
they will like this but it's not just
that though it's not a preference thing
it's also a thing where
there's so many writing issues
especially the first half of this show
it takes a while to get going and that's
expected with fantasy a lot of
characters and setting up this world
but the problem is is the main plot from
the start is really engaging
but you're gonna have a b plot that's
like in the start not that great it
takes a lot of screen time which
kind of makes you zone out and then they
add a c plot that's incredibly
boring and useless and that really
starts making you zone out so it's one
of those shows where
every fantasy show is trying to pull off
a game of thrones did having all these
different
areas to tackle and make them all
interesting which is really hard to do
and this has like three stories going on
and two of them at least the first half
just
really drag and it takes away from
momentum in the main story
that's what's the most frustrating thing
about this show however
it has some great episodes when the
stories collide and the plots collide
they're great
and then when it's separate not so great
but the acting
great ben barnes amazing as expected and
then
the lead actress who plays elena is
fantastic
every actor across the board is good
there's no one here that you're like oh
they're not good so that's a relief but
where the show suffers clearly is in its
writing also
it's gonna have some sloppy camera work
you'll see in certain episodes which
i'll pinpoint
in my spoiler review and questionable
directing but
overall it's a very decent show and
i really think unless you love fantasy
or read these books
i'd skip it and if you do love fantasy
and run the books you're going to enjoy
it i think you will get enough out of it
so
i don't think it's something to run and
go watch but if you're looking to kill
some time i think you'll get some reward
to it it's not completely
bad or useless i was able to finish it
so that's a plus already and i'm super
picky so
i do wonder how book fans will react
because i haven't read the books i don't
know if they're going to love this or be
disappointed but
it did feel like it was a little too
reliant on the book as well to make up
for
stuff in the show where maybe as a book
reader you can have patience because
you're like oh this is going to pay off
because i know what happens but
a lot of those things we don't get paid
off in season one so as someone watching
it i'm like
okay where is this going and it's it's
not fair to expect it as an excuse like
oh well don't worry later in the book
that character gets better or something
it's like well it still has to be good
now for the show
so when you're adapting books that's a
big challenge tv show writers have and i
feel like they failed a lot
in those areas in this show and another
thing i have to point
is there's a lot of bad action in this
meaning cgi is fine
the planning the action is okay but the
actual action itself
is really lame like you'll see moments
where they're using magic or you're
supposed to like blow wind
but it's like a little speck of dust or
when there's an explosion like a barrel
kind of breaks it's very
like laughable so that's frustrating too
because when you have action sequences
you want to go full in you don't want to
pull back and i feel like
it pulls back a lot but overall my
rating for the season of this show is
going to be a 7.4
let me know down below if you plan to
watch it and then let me know when you
do watch it what you thought of it you
can also go watch my spoiler review and
comment there we'll
break it down a little more and talk
about everything but yeah i really want
to hear what you guys
plan to do about the show if you're
going to give it the time of day or not
and if you enjoyed this review i'd love
it if you could subscribe i review a
bunch of shows movies i also do
celebrity interviews so you don't want
to miss that
please follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time